it is time for our pet vet segment with
dr jamie ogenstein of oasis animal
hospital in henderson
dr ogenstein we've talked in many recent
weeks about
health safety heat safety and protective
shade and it's just so discouraging to
know that we're reporting again on two
dogs being left
in a garage allegedly by their pet owner
and it's just so discouraging when we
hear these things they were left there
and they died
you know and it's such a it's so it's so
sad because it's such an easy thing
to prevent you make sure they've got
airflow and
protection from the heat and the sun
there's no reason
everybody knows nowadays there's no
reason for this to happen
and being left in a garage is just as
bad you've said before
if not worse than leaving them outdoors
isn't it
it is at least outdoors you're going to
get some airflow hopefully they can get
into shade but
in this in the garage if there's no
airflow
it gets extremely hot all right
dangerous oh it's very discouraging when
we report on those things all right
moving forward when it comes to
dog food there are so many options out
there but they're specifically something
you'd like owners to steer clear of and
that's green please tell us why
uh well it's actually not grain it's
grain
free diets in 2018 the fda finally
announced that there were
an increase in cases of heart disease
known as
dilated cardiomyopathy in breeds that
weren't getting it
and it's related to these grain free
exotic and boutique diets
and mostly the ingredients are peas
lentils legumes and potatoes of any form
they've been researching this ever since
and they have not figured out the cause
yet
and so nobody knows why so the best
thing that can be done is
don't feed a grain-free diet no matter
how good you think that
that product may be it's a fad that got
caught on it got picked up some
by some companies and they advertised it
well but nobody knows
why this is happening and so it's best
to just avoid grain free diets until
they figure out the cause
all right thank you for that
clarification we appreciate that we do
have some viewer questions submitted to
us today that we'd like to add
ann marie says or ask that is why are my
dogs sneezing
so much this past week well be the same
reason that most people are sneezing is
probably the dust and pollen in the air
possibly allergies
uh and so best thing talk to your
veterinarian about whether they can take
an antihistamine or
is there something else they might need
to help out better
okay peggy asks are the calming callers
worth the purchase because of course
we've got july 4th that's right around
the corner dr
ogenstein correct um
in my experience the calming callers
will only work for those dogs with a
very
mild anxiety and and response to the
fireworks
if your dog has a moderate to
severe anxiety no i would recommend you
talk to your veterinarian about getting
something
else they've some tranquilizers there's
some anti-anxiety medication
um those work much better than the
calming callers
so i don't usually recommend them okay
well that's good to know and of course
you know the dogs freak out from the
sounds we report on it every year
and um so stay home if need be just to
you know be there for your fur babies so
they don't freak out
exactly put on some calming music for
yourselves
all right thanks so much dr ogenstein we
appreciate your time we'll catch up with
you in the next few weeks
we're going to send it over to christian